et là il ya un nouveau rebondissement
dans l'héritage de karl lagerfeld la
mort du grand couturier français en
février 2019 pourrait bien provoquer un
feuilleton similaire à l'héritage de
johnny hallyday et oui en effet selon
parisien pour l'heure il n'y aurait pas
eu de réunion avec tous les héritiers
fait rarissime surtout que ça fait déjà
plus d'un an que karl lagerfeld et
décider des scellés n'ont pas décidé si
tout ça ça serait et serait en partie
due à l'expert comptable de le karl
lagerfeld qui ferait volontairement
traîner la faire on évoque aussi un
conflit d'intérêt entre les héritiers
oui alors bâti giabiconi mon pote que
j'embrasse sébastien jondeau son homme
de main ou encore françoise sa
gouvernante
alors il ya même le chat exactement
choupette exactement qui est assez
vénère non mais je vous dit qu'il valait
1 mais elle a dit ça se passera pas
comme ça l'a poussé un coup de griffe
tout à l'heure est ce que cette affaire
va prendre de l'ampleur
regardez-vous récap la médecine alors
que le couturier karl lagerfeld nous a
quittés en 2019 les questions autour de
son importante héritage sont toujours en
suspens alors qu'il ya quelques mois une
petite bière médiatique avait été lancée
pour déterminer qui étaient les noms
présents sur la liste des héritiers du
kaiser voilà aujourd'hui que c'est le
comptable de karl lagerfeld qui semble
faire traîner la procédure
le comptable en question âgée
aujourd'hui de 87 ans aurait décidé de
fermer son cabinet il ya un an
aujourd'hui reclus dans son appartement
est atteint par la maladie il ferait
traîner le dossier chez les héritiers en
attente parmi lesquels baptiste
giabiconi sébastien jondeau ou encore sa
gouvernante françoise qui s'occupe
aujourd'hui de la chatte choupette la
tension monte alors vers une nouvelle
affaire d'héritage avec celui de karl
lagerfeld
alors mes chéris d'amour oui mais chéri
d'amour qui a des infos sur cette
affaire peut-être géraldine maillet
rescue sablon l'héritage est mort à
l'âge et obscène d'accord moi j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] de savoir que qui va
hériter de quoi devenir ça ne nous
regarde pas je ne veux pas savoir je
trouve que c'est vraiment pas bien c'est
pas élégant et je veux je trouve qu'on a
rien à fâcher pas on n'a pas à savoir sa
salle et le responsable bien sûr des
personnes décédées c'est malin
enterrement la bce va le dire est la
direction des ressources humaines
c'est allé battre non c'est à dire que
pour le moins d'en estimer que c'était
sa fortune à peu près à 200 millions en
réalité c'est beaucoup plus et un
minimum à dire milliards oui oui c'est
ça c'est beaucoup plus que ça alors il
ya un inventaire affaire qui est
colossal puisque des oeuvres d'art iliad
immobilier ya un peu de tout donc on met
en responsabilité ce comptable bossent
et qui doit voir un boulot monstrueux ça
fait 15 ans l'histoire il est mort a dit
cela me février 2010 non non ça prend du
temps la ville et rhodia est très mal a
dit pareil oui oui mais même tout ça
n'est pas tout seul à faire ça un nom ça
va être un bordel terrible et en plus
c'est vrai que tout le monde se veut la
part du gâteau allemand on aura fait un
nom n'aura pas ce problème a maintenant
on regarde à exister un le comptable
hilario un vrai bon mais s'ils voient
que vous devriez donner les l'héritage
un des chroniqueurs c'est qui votre
chroniqueur préféré que vous devrez
célérité hérité quelqu'un d'autre d'un
chroniqueur de de toute l'année dernière
de quoi toutes les émissions la balance
rigolade balance composent l'ua tout la
forme d'une masse intéressant ça hakim
il ya un choix à un chroniqueur fm en
référé de ces préfets humainement pas
aimer riant mais si que vous préférez
vous personnellement je voulais
influencé par que vous étiez alors vous
vous êtes la famille est ce qu'il est
sûre on n'est pas là déjà dans
l'héritage vous serez déjà forcément
voilà un sujet qui est l'héritage et
forcément il n'a pas franchement le
bateau de 35 m je veux vous dire
sans les villas moi je vais à leucate je
donne tout oui à qui je donne tout accès
non voulez que je dise vraiment oui et
pas d'une question d'héritage que je
veux pas qu'on parle de ça ça fait de la
peine alors si vous voulez je n'ai je
pas cela remet à gauche font alors juste
qu'avec un humaniste vous prêt alors on
compte les émissions c'est la fin qu il
y en a un que j'adore vraiment que
j'aime énormément
c'est vraiment mon coup de coeur de l'an
dernier c'est bernard laporte vers la
porte je l'adoré voilà de btp je
l'adorais pourquoi parce que je trouve
qu'il est franc il est drôle il est
toujours de bonne humeur il est simple
il se prend pas la tête
voilà ils cherchèrent la journée tête
j'ai toujours eu un truc pour les
sportifs vous le savez et c'est vrai que
bernard il a une mentalité de sportifs
quand je l'appelle c'est vrai qu'il peut
rester cinq minutes avec payer comme un
vice président il est vice-président de
la de la paix vous l'avez fait venir
pour lancer un top ce que j'adore il est
bien sûr m à gamarde réduit l'avancé de
top 14 et les jurés vous savez ce qu'il
ya et alors j'ai appelé bernard laporte
à 13h c'est quand même énorme et julie
il est vice-président de la fédération
mondiale de rugby et quand je l'appelle
il est toujours on a toujours
l'impression que c'est le proviseur qui
l'appelle c'est à dire qu'il avait
montée d'angoissé et après ils appellent
même cela ledger ski laquelle elle
s'occupe de lui aussi pour laquelle
cyril maps et je crois que c'est grave
et je dors ce mec parce qu'il est
tellement simple voilà il a et voilà je
voulais mais c'est vraiment quelqu'un
voilà je vous dis qu'elle a c'est un
super mec
chez les femmes à bâcher les femmes
c'est bouder les bouder jamais si c'est
vrai oui oui mathieu on revient sur la
sphère bien sûr parce que moi ce qui
m'avait choqué les cas merci de ton nom
c'est bien qu'il soit là hiroka dans
l'émission la vraie vie en revanche je
peux vous dire un truc sur les interdits
sur le sur le sur les testaments
par exemple mon agent de terre me dit ça
serait bien de faire un testament ouais
il me dit vous allez voir que si vous le
faites avec de la logique vous mettez la
famille et où il y aura 25 personnes si
vous y allez avec le coeur à votre âge
il y aura pas dix personnes
effectivement je suis arrivé à 8 non je
vous jure pas bien mais je reviens à
nantes donc je préfère hérité quelqu'un
qui est milliardaire
arrêtez arrêtez de croire ça
scemama ce que je suis d'hôtel j'ai
suivi les techniques très riche agent
mais non c'est pas vrai voyage au regard
des gens minimes et la zambie
à oui c'est vrai mais après il ya des
gens qui pouvaient de neige pana parts
et d'autres une montre c'est pas
forcément beaucoup d'argent et tout mais
c'est des gens que vous voulez bon bref
à tenir sur cette histoire juste moi ce
qui m'avait choqué à l'époque c'était
baptiste giabiconi fast l'émission sept
à huit et qu'il arrive écrit dix ans et
on a mis jeudi quand même les choses et
qu'ils disent je suis le premier sur la
liste or ils ne savaient pas personne ne
le savait personne n'avait vu le
testament et personne ne connaissait
mais qu'est ce que vous en savez si karl
lagerfeld lui a pas dit avant n'est pas
si bastien et on lui a demandé à quelle
place ils étaient si l'un a pondu une
question non humains bah oui mais si tu
la réponse à une question
ça leur fera exactement s'il n'y a pas
une promesse c'est baptiste battisti la
vraie il avait un vrai amour pour cas là
mais j'ai pas les comptes
est ce que j'ai dit est ce que je fais
et c'est normal et on nous propose une
interview dans cet avis qui s'est fait
un peu voilà il est d'acta vous ferait
été très beau c'était maladroit qui
arrivait pas pour dire je suis dans un
miroir il salue maladroit parce que si
son papa de substitution lui à premier
lui a dit je te promets je te donne tout
et ballu on nous pose la question et bat
peut-être naïve par amour et il va te
répondre regardez moi je dis la même
chose et bien moi je dis je te promets
je te donne 20 bernard gellez canicas vu
dans cet avis et vous serez après que
les neuf et moi j'en profite testament
jeudi 3 face caméra ma famille si on
vient vous voir on vous demande
l'héritage dit non c'est que des dettes
c'est que des crédits dit non il n'y a
pas d'airé talent j'en profite
arrête de parler d'héritage non veulent
vraiment qu'ils publient
reportage syrie la trique immédiate
parmi les six héritiers 7h au fait
est-ce que je joue pas la montre pour
que je pète pas ça à ma gauche une part
de plus dans les détails il avait raison
c'est vrai qu'une chatte sammer très
vite il chaleur à 15 h soupe est
imprécis de morandini tout ça à gali mme
magali c'est vrai que nous en tant que
téléspectateur on s'en fiche un peu ces
désordres voilà c'est ça je suis
d'accord avec magali c'est vrai qu'en
fait on a eu johnny hallyday bon après
c'était de jaunisse voilà c'est ça en
était bon on aime on n'aime pas me steny
dole nikon je veux dire car la gare fief
end et il a fait quelque chose juste
avant de décéder
il en fait ce qu'il veut je suis assez
d'accord avec vous voilà après on n'a
pas à s'immiscer
je rejoins un peu et je rebondis sur ce
que disait géraldine t on dire sens et
on n'a pas besoin de vous dire
bizarrement les deux meilleures
interventions ce sont les personnes qui
sont les plus chères à john grabow avoue
nathan et c est la grande question
vaudois possible à la place de l'ormeau
bon voila c'était bien changé en deux
mois en fait
[Applaudissements]
bravo pas que je n'aime pas non plus
[Rires]
l'audience ça va pas tu es pas été
terrible
alors je dirai demain matin 6 7 me v'là
[Rires]
magali c'est mon avenir c'est une
téléspectatrice les magazines c'est des
gros bisous magali des fans
magali et midget génial je t'écris sur
l'héritage te soutient mathieu mad men
ne sera pas vite le passera la main
gauche ne soyez pas avec lui